the potential criminality of Donald
Trump's attempts to influence the
investigation into collusion between his
campaign and Russian officials continues
to grow
previously we told you that Donald Trump
asked fired FBI director James Comey to
stop the investigation into disgrace
national security adviser Michael Flynn
we also know that Donald Trump fired
James Comey to quote remove some of the
pressure that Donald Trump was under as
I told you yesterday and already as we
discussed yesterday legal expert Jeffrey
Toobin said that is a potentially
criminal admission to obstruction of
justice that's where we were as of
yesterday but it is leak o'clock as
often is the case every single day these
days we have now further learned that
Donald Trump asked to American
intelligence officials to help him push
back against the FBI investigation into
the collusion that is suspected to have
taken place between his campaign and
Russia Donald Trump made separate
appeals to both the Director of National
Intelligence Daniel Coates and to
Admiral Michael Rogers the director of
the NSA urging them to go public and
deny that there is any evidence of
collusion during the 2016 election
between Donald Trump and Russian
officials
now what did Coates and Rogers do they
did the right thing they refused to
comply with Donald Trump's request which
they both determined to be inappropriate
according to two current and two former
officials who spoke on the condition of
anonymity Donald Trump's conversation
with Mike Rogers was documented what is
called contemporaneously which means
immediately after it took place if you
remember I guess at this point it's hard
to keep track of the days but we now are
aware of the existence of this memo that
James Comey wrote after Donald Trump
asked him to ease off of the Michael
Flynn investigation
these contemporaneous memos are
considered to be both reliable and
typically accurate they are taken at the
time by responsible intelligence
officials and it is unclear if there's a
similar memo that was prepared with by
Coates but this is
really starting to go beyond possibly
criminal into direct obstruction of
justice and it's just baffling how he
treats the intelligence community as if
they're beneath him and yeah Serbian to
him entirely because of course they are
somewhat quasi independent organizations
and they don't have to do whatever the
president asks of them sure obviously
they can investigate the president and I
don't think Trump is used to that
because he's used to operating
businesses where he was the be-all and
end-all
oh yeah he was the last word on
everything the buck stopped with him for
everything in his life basically until
now memos we are going to at some point
be dealing with many many requests for
memos to be released if 2016 was the
year of memes 2017 is likely the year of
memos and I want you to understand what
this is this is not only that Donald
Trump asked intelligence officials to
lend him political help Donald Trump
asked members of the intelligence
community to publicly release false
statements a former senior intelligence
official said that the request that was
made quote the problem wasn't so much
asking them to issue statements it was
asking them to issue false statements
about an ongoing investigation and it
goes even further in addition to the
request to Coates and Rogers senior
White House officials sounded out top
intelligence officials about the
possibility of intervening directly with
James Comey to encourage the FBI to stop
investigating Michael Flynn according to
people familiar with the matter can we
ask him to shut down the investigation
are you able to assist in this matter
one official said of the line of
questioning from the White House this is
now unquestionably beyond any doubt well
into Watergate territory in terms of the
cover-up simple question is this how an
innocent person behaves asking call me
to cut the investigation firing Comey to
stop the investigation asking other
intelligence officials to publicly lie
about the investigation this is not how
an innocent person conducts themselves I
think the question is would this be
considered obstruction of justice the
problem is is story
that's usually used as a secondary or
tertiary charge against the president
when it came to the Watergate scandal is
one of three charges against Nixon and
with Lewinsky Gaeta was one of two
against Bill Clinton because you brought
up Watergate if you're skeptical that
this is looking more and more like
Watergate
let me put up on the screen for you an
article that was released by the New
York Times on August 9th of 1974 in a
sharp setback to his fight against
impeachment President Nixon admitted
today that six days after the Watergate
burglary he ordered a halt to the
investigation of the break-in for
political as well as national security
reasons and that he kept the evidence
from his lawyers and supporters on the
House Judiciary Committee he made the
admission in a statement accompanying
the release of transcripts of three
conversations on June 23rd 1972 which he
said might further damage his case
against impeachment it is virtually a
foregone conclusion the president added
that the White House would vote to
impeach him but he said he hoped the
Senate would look at all the evidence in
perspective and vote to acquit him the
president disclosed that he had tried to
keep the FBI from pursuing an
investigation of the source of the money
that financed the Watergate break-in
this was widely regarded in Congress as
an admission of guilt to the charge of
obstructing justice a criminal offense
and then it goes on to cite the the law
in which that is a that is a criminal
offense that is sounding very similar to
what we are seeing now prevent the FBI
from investigating don't turn over
evidence this is no longer he said
versus he said in terms of Trump versus
Comey
and his memos it is now Trump said
versus they said the day the the veve a
is multiple heads of US intelligence
agencies with documentation it is a
lifelong conman and notorious liar
Donald Trump versus multiple heads of
intelligence agencies all telling a very
coherent story you believe who you want
to pat right I think the connections to
Watergate continue to grow especially as
we learn now that there could be taped
conversations that
Trump regards himself as above the law
as Nixon did yes these keep growing I
forgot about the tapes part I mean I
talked only about memos but then there's
this possibility of tapes which Donald
Trump alluded to on Twitter it's getting
bad folks it's getting bad
I still get every one very few now but
every once in a while I still get an
email from someone saying David
there is no Trump Russia thing there's
just nothing to look into it's happening
way less frequently than it was a month
ago I'm sure there are people who say
that the Russia scandal is distracting
for more important issues but I think
that's an entirely different point yeah
I mean when are we going to reopen that
investigation into Hillary's emails and
Obama's tan suit that's really what we
should be focusing on here send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman